it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all that exclusive low discounts to
start shopping scan the QR code on your
screen right now or visit cbsdeals.com
good housekeepings Chief technologist
Rachel Rothman is here to join us what's
going on what do you got for us being a
pod absolutely love this one for the
kitchen if you have limited dexterity
you pop it in just like this we can
spray it on top
just a nice Finishing Touch and it's
able to give that those spices fresh and
so when you do the fresh grind on it
it's going to give it that really
impactful it's like you're in a fancy
restaurant
and it makes it so easy and you just pop
them in you pop them out put another one
on this yeah so no cross contamination
with this so I know sometimes you know
you get the salt or the pepper on your
hands
it's a great housewarming gift are you
are you loving the product popcorn you
have popcorn's great and adding that
extra seasoning how much so uh you can
get the salt and pepper with the device
for 36 dollars and you can get the three
pack with it um for uh forty eight
dollars up to 45 off so a really
fantastic deal and it comes out I think
I could have really cool really clever
really easy yeah you don't cook I know
that's what but I think
yeah we're in the same boat it's okay
yes yes yes so the limit Power Pro I
don't know about you we are always
fighting for outlets in our house we
have so many devices these days this can
charge up to five different devices it
has two ACS that are grounded and it has
surge protection it has two USB and a
USBC so it's really fast charging and it
also has that surge protection so that
you don't need to worry about any any of
those spikes only 25 this one sells
super fast and you're getting this
really fantastic deal 58 off 25 that's a
great deal you're having a backyard
party NATO is a very great backyard all
right so we're invited I'm gonna bring
the tika Tunes Pro so this is a
Bluetooth portable speaker and it has an
IP X6 rating which means that it's water
resistant so you can have it outside you
can have it even by the bath so I like
to set some Ambience they all connect
could you see you can sync up to a
hundred of them what really outfit your
entire backyard yeah it'll play music
oh hey now all right all right all right
and it has three different lighting
modes with it
um I think that's cool this is really
cool it's 54 and it has this really
convenient handle so you can just take
it with you really easy to use controls
on top and it also comes with the stake
and it goes up to four feet and it you
can adjust the hiding at six inch
increments so it's this really fantastic
set take anywhere with you pair up
multiple ones and for fifty four dollars
it's a fantastic deal so get a lot of
them great price all right Rachel
Rothman thank you so much we appreciate
you of course we partnered with all
these companies to get these deals you
can buy anything that you saw in many
more products scan the QR code on your
screen right now or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping right now
we're